So I've got some tough medicine for you.
The truth is that everybody in this room
needs to radically rethink
how you communicate,
especially how you write,
if you want anything to stick
in this distracted digital world.
I don't care if you're a student,
if you're an academic,
if you're a scientist,
you're a CEO, a manager.
I'll tell you what the data told me
that your friends won't tell you,
which is almost nobody listens to
or reads most of what you write.
Most of the stuff
that you agonize thinking about,
they pay no attention to.
And how do I know this?
Well, I learned it the hard way.
I've dedicated my entire life
to mass producing words.
I was a journalist by training.
Started at the "Oshkosh Northwestern."
Worked my way up
to covering the presidency
for "The Washington Post"
and the "Wall Street Journal."
And I started two media companies,
all about mass producing words.
Politico and now Axios.
And at my current company,
the entire premise of the company
is to teach journalists
and then CEOs, academics and others
how to use far fewer words.
So why?
Why, if I spent my entire life
writing lots of words,
do I want people to use fewer of them?
Because the data -- and you -- made me.
If you actually look
at what you're doing --
One of the most interesting things
about technology,
one of the creepiest things
about technology is
businesses know so much about you.
What you do, where you go, what you buy.
And in the case of a media company,
how you consume information.
And the data about how you consume
information is eye-popping.
And to be honest, for me, really humbling.
And led to this journey about,
wow, if I'm looking at this data
and the data basically says:
you read almost nothing.
You skim. You might look at a headline.
You might look at a subject line.
But you're basically
not reading the stories,
in my case, that we were producing.
And the most humbling moment,
the eye-opening, the aha moment for me:
I was a journalist, I was at Politico
writing columns about President Obama.
And we wrote this column,
and I looked at the traffic numbers
and the White House had to respond to it.
And boy, was I feeling cool and smart ...
until I looked at the data.
So back then you had to
paginate pages online.
And so, you know, you had to click
from one page to the next to keep reading.
And I looked at the data.
This was a 1600-word column
that everyone in Washington
was talking about,
that had me feeling so confident.
And I realized almost nobody
went past the first page.
(Laughter)
It gets worse.
On one page, there's only 450 words.
And I hid a lot
of the good stuff at the end.
And so it turns out
that people were responding, sharing,
talking about a story
that almost nobody read.
And so it put me on sort of
this journey, this discovery.
I'm like, really,
like, nobody reads anything?
Is this true everywhere, is it just me,
is there something about my writing?
So I called my friends
at the "New York Times."
I called our friends at Facebook.
I started to talk to academics
and try to figure out,
well, what's going on here.
Because I had a choice at this point.
I could give up on all of you.
I could give up on humanity.
I could give up on my career.
Or I could do what
basically Jeff Bezos would do
if he's trying to sell you a shoe
or get you to buy a book.
Which is, what is the data telling us?
What do you want? What are you doing?
And that data was showing that one,
everybody was getting hit
with more information than ever before
and is perpetually distracted,
all because of the internet.
You skim. You don't really read.
And you share stuff without even bothering
to see what it actually means
or what the story might say.
And if you think about it,
the deeper I dug,
the more it actually made sense.
For people who are my age or older,
like once upon a time,
the iPhone didn't exist.
The Android didn't exist.
There was no Facebook.
There was no Google.
If you wanted to learn
about something new,
you had to go to an encyclopedia.
You wanted to look up a word,
you went to a dictionary.
If you were waiting for news,
you had to wait for the evening news
or the morning newspaper.
And then suddenly 2007,
that period comes along,
and now all of us had the opportunity
to have a smartphone
with astonishing capabilities
to give us access to more information
than at any point of humanity.
Any idea we had, anything we didn't know,
we could Google it.
Any idea we had,
no matter how stupid it was,
we could share it.
And not only could we share it,
we could find other people
who would applaud,
who would follow us, who'd fan us.
And suddenly, oh my gosh,
like, we've got all this access
to mass information at scale.
And you could do this for free.
You could do this for free.
So suddenly we're getting hit
with all this information,
and I don't think our species
was built to keep up with it.
I talked to a guy
at the University of Maryland
who's studied students
for the last decade,
and he basically found that even
when you choose to read something,
even when you make the choice
that this is important,
you spend on average
26 seconds looking at it.
Review.org and others
have looked at how many times
do you look at your screen in a day.
They found it's at least 250 times
you're checking your phone.
And for those that
don't think that's true,
think about how many times
you've either checked it
or thought about checking it
since I started babbling.
(Laughter)
Our data shows that more often than not,
if you share a story on social media,
you never read it.
Think about that: like there’s something
about a headline or a photo
that got you so jacked up
that you're going to share it
like you're a little lemming.
And we all do it because
our brains are being, like,
flooded with information.
And what I thought
when I did the discovery,
I thought, for sure
the brain must be getting rewired.
And you hear that often.
There's very little scientific proof
that that's true.
What happened and what
we think is happening
is, as a species, we've always
been prone to distraction.
We think we're good multitaskers.
Almost nobody is.
We're good at doing one thing
if you're focused on it.
The University of California,
Irvine, studied this.
They studied our distractibility
and found that if you get
distracted on something,
it takes you 20 minutes to truly refocus.
Now think about your day.
It's just awash in distraction.
Awash in words: tweeted words,
texted words, Slacked words, email words.
Words, words, words.
And then you peck at your
little computer looking for more.
So no wonder nobody's paying attention
to almost anything you're saying or doing.
No wonder it's so hard to get people
to pay attention to anything.
So at Axios, as we thought about this,
we said, listen, if the consumer’s saying
they want more information quicker
and they're not going to spend
that much time
and you want to stay in journalism,
what would you do? What would you do?
And our solution was
what we call Smart Brevity,
that people want smart content,
essential content.
But they want it delivered efficiently,
as fast as humanly possible.
And we saw it in how people
were getting our information,
how they were getting it elsewhere.
And so we built a whole company around it
to teach journalists how to do it.
And journalists
kind of adapted right away.
And suddenly we had
awesome readership almost overnight,
people in the White House,
CEOs, tech leaders.
And then two interesting things
happened after that.
I started to get not ten or 20,
literally hundreds of notes
from readers saying,
"Thank you, you're trying
to save me time. I can tell."
I never asked for a thank you,
especially when you cover politics,
you're lucky not to get hit by a shoe,
much less actually
have someone thank you for it.
But I was like, "Oh, that is interesting."
And then about a year and a half in,
we started to get calls from companies,
from the NBA, from startups,
and almost all were saying the same thing:
"Hey, our executives, our people,
they're reading Smart Brevity,
but they won't read anything
that we do internally.
This led me on another journey
to figure out why people can't get people
to read about things
that are happening at their company
or happening at their school
or happening at their startup.
And it turned out that basically
people were vomiting so many words
in all these places
that nobody was paying attention to it.
And that's where we thought,
oh, Smart Brevity could work
in almost any setting.
So we get a call from the CIA,
the head of the CIA.
They call us, and they say,
"Listen, can you guys come in
and talk to our team
about how spies can essentially give
a much more crisper explanation
of what they're seeing on the ground?
Like, what are the threats?
They're not great communicators.
These messages are meandering."
So my partner goes in, talks to the CIA,
explains the tricks and tips
I’m going to give you in a second.
And in the audience is a guy
who writes the Presidential Daily Brief,
and this was under Donald Trump,
and he would write it, go in,
and they would brief him.
And he was so enamored with this idea
of communicating more effectively
that he quit and now works for us,
teaching other people
how to communicate more effectively.
(Laughter)
I'm not blaming Trump.
It's because of us, because of Axios.
Around the same time, Jamie Dimon,
one of the most famous CEOs
of our generation,
he writes his annual letter.
It's 32,000 words long,
about his observations
on banking and on the world.
32,000 words is basically a book.
So he's probably lucky
if even his family members read it.
So his staff calls us, and they say,
"Hey, listen. It seems
like you guys are good
at getting people
to pay attention to information.
Could you do a Smart Brevity
version of it?"
So we took his most important points,
turned 32,000 words into a couple hundred,
and voila, they got much more engagement,
much more traction
in people seeing what's important,
remembering what's important.
So what I want to leave you with
are what are some of the basic tips.
Because you probably know,
you're frazzled, you're distracted,
you can see it.
When you're trying to send a message,
what are the things that you could
do differently, starting today,
to become a vastly
more effective communicator?
Number one, stop being selfish.
Stop being selfish.
What do I mean by that?
So much of writing is self-indulgent.
We write about what we care about,
and we write at the length
that we want to write about.
We don't think about
the whole purpose of it,
which is what is the person
that I'm writing this for, or talking to,
what do they actually need to know?
What do they actually care about?
Reverse the way
you think about communicating.
At our company, the first two words
of our manifesto are: "Audience first."
How do you serve the people
that you're trying to reach?
The Holy Father himself
has blessed this concept indirectly.
So Pope Francis
just gave a speech recently
in Slovakia, where he was
talking to priests
about the homilies that they're giving.
And he said, “You have to stop giving
30 and 40 minute homilies,
and they should be 10 minutes.
Because no one’s listening to you.
You’re losing them.
People don’t pay attention that long.”
And he joked when he made the announcement
that the loudest applause
came from the nuns
because, in his words, they're the ones
who have to suffer
through your long-windedness.
(Laughter)
So point two is: grab me.
Whenever you're communicating --
again, I don't care if it's in an email,
if it's a tweet, if it's a note,
if it's a memo to a friend, grab me.
What is the most important thing,
the reason you're writing?
What is that one thing, if you only had
that 26 seconds I mentioned,
what is the one thing
you want me to remember about it?
Which is related to tip three,
which is: just keep it simple.
Keep it simple.
Like think of that one sentence,
one sentence is better than two sentences.
One paragraph is better
than two paragraphs.
Use simple, strong words.
There's a reason you're taught
a simple sentence structure
when you're a little kid.
It still works effectively today.
It still works effectively.
Keep it simple.
If you're going to write about a banana,
you're not going to call it
an elongated yellow piece of fruit.
You're going to call it a banana.
If you're going to talk
about someone lying,
you're not going to say prevaricate,
you're going to say lie.
Keep it simple.
Which relates as well to point four,
which is: be human.
Write like a human.
I see this in journalism all the time.
I don't understand
what happened to our species
that when you put a pen in our hand
or a keyboard in front of us,
we suddenly stiffen up,
think we're a Harvard professor
or we're Walt Whitman,
and we try to show off in our writing.
Like, if I was talking to you in the bar,
I'm not going to use SAT words,
I'm not going to talk in acronyms.
I'm not going to use wordy clauses.
I'm going to talk
like I'm talking to you now.
I'm going to talk like a human.
So stop, stop using those big terms.
You think that people think you're smart
when you use them? They don't.
They just want to throw a shoe at you.
(Laughter)
Which leads me to point five,
which is just stop.
Just stop.
The greatest gift
that you can give yourself and others
in this cluttered world
is their time back and is your time back.
Use as few words,
as few sentences as humanly possible
so that that person
gets the message you want
and you both get the time back
that you deserve.
And I can tell you this,
I've seen it in my own life.
If you just start to think
about the efficiency of communication,
if you put into practice a couple
of the tips that I just talked about,
you will see in your own mind
that you start to think more clearly,
talk more clearly, write more clearly.
And you'll see ultimately
that it's selfishly good for you
because you'll be heard again.
Thank you.
(Applause)